Quantum theory, the world of smaller particles, is actually the effect of mathematics, and
I would say that the future is for quantum mathematics
Mathematics is also done by mathematicians, we do it with the brain, how our brains were created?
Well, millions of years of evolution. So I think our concepts
Too much of things are affected to see who is around us
So we talk about the space because we sort of move in space
We are moving in time. We count because we see things. We throw stones
We want to half the stone track and its speed
Thus calculus, for example, is based on the idea of ​​speed or slope
So I actually think that our mind is a very large kind of set of everyday experience
So you may think that math is a kind of stop doing if we move to a new circle
For example, very large, such as the universe, or very small, as a primary particle scientist.
But the wonderful thing: this did not happen. So math was
Very successful in conquering, and certainly I think, that material experience
General relativity
Einstein's theory is a good example
He needs a concept of curved space. It turned out that Riemann and others
In the nineteenth century, they had already thought about it. They thought, there are two dimensions, three dimensions
Why do not there be a quantitative number of dimensions?
The abstract thinking of athletes was a kind of advanced thinking in quantum theory
As you know, even if you sit and meditate for a million years will not come with quantum laws
Mechanics because they are very strange. Thus, nature naturally imposed on us
It was like a very painful process. We had to leave many very cherished concepts
For example, the fact that the world system is predictable. Quantum mechanics is just the way nature works
You see it very clearly at the level of atoms and elementary particles
If you took many atoms together, then in some sense many of the features of quantum mechanics
Are of the drifting type. We do not notice that because we are manufacturers of such as 10 to 24 molecules usually
There are many things that you have to give up on quantum mechanics. The first is that you can not figure out the answer to all the questions
So, for example, usually, I would say, well, this is the pen, I know where it is, and if you drop it
I know what speed is. It moves. Quantum mechanics says everything is okay
You can know either position or speed, so nearly half of the questions are not answerable
This is really weird, because how will I describe the pen then?
But there is another thing, which is that even if you want to describe
How things move, they never have a specific answer. So, like if you
A classic object like a pen, now you can say "How do I go from A to B?
Well there will be shorter roads. As you throw a stone you will go like this from A to B.
I will know exactly how I went
This is like the optimal path, I can calculate this, math about this. Now, if you are
The particles of quantum mechanics, you are basically free to go in any possible
The road, so you know, may really be very strange trails that go all in such a way
And what physics will do, it will give a definite probability to all of these
Possible scenarios. If for example I want to go from work to home
I know very well what path I take
But if you are an electron that moves for example, from one atom to another atom
It's more like these curves, so everything is in terms of probability.
Quantum probability is something, it's like, complex number, if you take squared abs,
The possibilities become actual.
So for example, one thing that is because of this funny kind of stuff, what can happen is
Instead, you know, even if you're thinking where particles are located,
Now it can be here, or can be here, maybe you say, well there is a certain possibility
It's A, and the probability of it's B.
But the particles of quantum mechanics can be half here and another half will be there, at the same time.
So this is very strange.
It's like to take a point, divide it into two parts dot placed here, and put one there
Thus quantum mechanics bases are partially captured probability,
But it has a kind of very strange phenomena built in it, and it ... you have a kind of deep drilling and foundation of things
It happens, you know, all at the same time
Makes quantum mechanics very difficult to absorb
It has been said, you know, if you say you understand quantum mechanics that you are just a liar, because that is it
This is something in our intuition we simply can not understand
Physicists were thinking, well, we need some things, for example, to describe transformations in corn
How to go from case to case
Well, we need something, and then they discovered that it is called a matrix, and that it is actually known, of course, in mathematical literature.
But to understand
The concepts that came, such as Hilbert's places and wave functions, were mathematics that was partially developed at the time
But I would say then that the physicists really ran with it
At this point, I would say mathians are
Try to catch up
Understand, you know
Not only language, but also the power of the concept. Because there is something incredible
Nature in quantum theory is ideal for the mathematical mind
Because mathematicians do not study one object
They really are really thinking about the whole family. Category, all possible things. So, all the numbers at the same time, or everything is possible
For geometric shapes. What quantum mechanics says is perfection, because I do not consider it one way
I'm thinking of the space of all the tracks. In fact, I give you something else. I give you a way
In fact, the probability of each path is possible
So in some way, you can gather all over these different tracks. We call this amount over the course of history
and he...
Again, the concept is very funny, since we think of history as something, too
Some things, some facts that happen. Quantum mechanics
History is all possible scenarios at the same time. Thus there is a certain way to
Consider many different things at the same time. And even one
The coolest application to all this is, node theory. So if you have a node, like this
Connected like this, so it's ... it's ... I just
Draw here the projection, but there is a certain path in three dimensions, and, you know,
The athletes want to distinguish. This one is knotted, and this one is not. So, if you knot
Theory, you want to study the knot in the general. The space of each node is possible. Really
Quantum theory comes to salvation
It is a very effective way to describe this node. Young physicists will not be surprised anymore
For example Niels Bohr or
Albert Einstein, who were really fighting this concept. I often think, you know, at some point there will be a generation of mathematicians
This species grows, and grows with quantum theory, and they are likely to apply these kinds of rules in a very natural way.
Brady: "They started stealing your things, are not they?
exactly. So, the wonderful thing is that there are some very deep ones
Mathematical problems; abstract mathematical problems, such a classification of each node
Or think of four or six dimensions of space, a mere fact of interested mathematics arguments
Now there is a set of these problems that have already been solved using quantum theory. I think he is like a good mathematician
It has a toolbox full of everything: sports engineering
Calculus, number theory,
As you know, the rules of modern physics should be there
It's just a very effective way to deal with some problems, and I actually ... think that many mathematicians are surprised that
The information was flowing in the other direction. Physicists were surprised, because they saw quantum
Mathematicians, so I say, took these ideas
Circulate them to higher levels
It's like having a great student and you know everything you know
And then the student takes much more, because it is again
This is the beauty of mathematics. It is, in a sense, inherent in reality, but then not. Difficult to meet
This mathematician is not ...
I don "t think so
Plato; believes that, as you know, primaries are only there, and have nothing to do with the fact that there are
Three pens here. That number three is there
Thus, there is this kind of
Interesting type to
Oscillation between mathematics
Absorbs
Facts from reality
And then the kind of taking a journey of fantasy, going in directions that the physicist says, wait a moment did not
In fact we have the intention to go and do, to do this kind of crazy things
Brady: "Was this appearance of mathematics out of physics a difficult birth?
Something causing problems?
Yup . Two-way, I think
What you know, physicists say that mathematics is very attractive
But it is like a black hole that can make you disappear, because you will be separated from reality.
Odysseus, to connect yourself to the mast of the ship is not enticed by the beauty of mathematics
Because he
Many of the great ideas in physics were very painful and unsophisticated and ugly
Initially. It took some time to appreciate
Quantum theory is a beautiful thing. This is the rivalry of the physics part. From the mathematics part,
I think this is, you know, physicists sometimes look at them as a kind of plumber, and they, you know, they make their hands dirty,
They deal with this messy thing that is actually called
It's beautiful, as a mathematician, you can go to this Platonic world where there is some perfection. So there too
I think a few mathematicians were not already
Impressed with the material ideas. They may say, well
As you know, it may be kind of ... this is probably ... one or two areas where it is appropriate, but not for my practical field,
Which is ancient. Then definitely
Who left the field
There were some material ideas that proved to be very powerful
I feel like it is like a wave, you think it will not hurt you until you hit, then suddenly become underwater
In physics we really have a crisis, and the crisis is that we have two
Great theories describing the world.
One is the canton
Theory: It's ideal for elementary particles. The other is relative, used to describe large structures in the universe
But the point is the clash of these two things, and they collide because these great physical laws. They include
Such as black holes, and perhaps most importantly, the Big Bang, where the rules of physics collapse.
So this is very noticeable that the theory that you have to describe actually may fail at the very core. And
We believe that, in a sense, the only solution is
To achieve quantum mechanics in it. So somehow we have to meld these two images. It's not enough to do quantum mechanics
It's not enough to do mathematics geometry. We know that this happens, because the universe works,
As you know, as we speak, the laws of nature are fully functioning
There is no collapse anywhere. That means we have to come out with something
Deeper than mathematics geometry
Now what?
This, I think, is a big secret. We have some ideas
So, the idea may be that math geometry or something like that
Thermodynamics, a theory that describes essentially the materials. So, if I think of this table, it shows me that it is very powerful
But I know it is a large group of molecules
I feel the air around me, and feel a certain temperature
But there is nothing like the temperature of these particles and only the up and down
So it can only be like this physical sheet, if we zoom in, zoom in, zoom in
I will definitely see molecules, atoms and elementary particles, and there is no paper anymore
Can it be if the zoom is in the same space, at what point I see pixels?
See something else? As you know, we were probably thinking it was pure information, such as zeros of them. So, I find that absolutely
Breathtaking. Because if you are able to come up with a piece of math
This is more fundamental than the space, from the geometry of mathematics, I think it will be
Revolution of all mathematics
just imagine
And so they are going ...
Window translation by: Shuan Hamid Twitter: @shwan_hamid